هل هناك اتصالات بين الطرفين هل هناك نوع
من المناقشات
نعم كانت هناك اتصالات منذ اليوم الاول
للحرب وما زال التواصل مستمرا الاستخبارات
والدوائر العسكريه ووزارات الخارجيه
واطراف ثالثه كلها ضالعه في الاتصال ايضا
مسؤولون سابقون هناك اتصالات يوميه وفي
بعض الاحيان عبر وساطات من اطراف ثالثه
كانت هناك دوما مناقشات واحد علاماتها
تبادل والسجناء والذي لا يحدث من فراغ
والذي لعبت فيه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
دور الرئيسي لانجاحه نعم كانت هناك
مناقشات وستستمر وهي احد اسباب استمرار
الرحلات الجويه من اسطنبول الى موسكو عبر
الخطوط التركيه التي تسير ما لا يقل عن
اربع رحلات يوميه بسبب ان هناك اطراف تقوم
بالرحله ذهابا وعوده يوميا بين موسكو
ين ماسكا نعلم انه كانت هناك امال بل كان
هناك تقارير تشير الى ان هذا العام سيكون
عام المفاوضات بين الروس والاوكرانيين
الان وصلنا الى منتصف هذا العام والمؤشرات
تؤكد عكس ذلك متى يمكن ان نرى مفاوضات هل
سيحدث ذلك يوما ما
اتوقع لذلك ان يبدا في الحدوث انطلاقا من
سبتمبر والذي ستكون فيه صوره اوضح بما
يجعلنا نتوقع ما سيحدث بين سبتمبر وديسمبر
ورجح ان يكون الهجوم الاوكرانيين ناجحا في
بعض المناطق وفشلا في اخرى ولن يكون لذلك
علاقه بكفاءه الاوكرانيين او الروس وانما
بحجم الاشخاص الذين سيمكن للاتحاد الروسي
تجنيدهم ضمن قواته وحجم العتاد الذي سيكون
بحوزتها اذا قرر المسؤولون استخدامه ومن
الجانب الاوكراني نعم لديهم قوات ملتزمه
ولكنها ليست بالحجم الملائم كما لديهم
تجهيزات ولكن هناك نوع من الحدود له فقد
دابوا خلال الشهرين الماضيين على تكرار
انهم يحتكمون على 98% مما يحتاجون لبدء
هجومهم لكن على صعيدا اخر راينا الرئيسكي
يزور القاده الاوروبيين لتقليص حجم
توقعاتهم من اله
لماذا يبادر زيلينسكي الى تقليص حجم
الانتصارات بدلا من توسيعها للحصول على
مساعدات ودعم اكثر اليس هناك تناقض في هذه
المساله
هم يعرفون انه اذا كانت انتظاراتهم عاليه
وان الاوكرانيين لا يؤدون بشكل قوي او في
حال فشل محاوله طرد الروس من بعض المناطق
من دون ان يتم ذلك فساعتها سيبدا عدد كبير
من الدول في القول لهم حسنا لقد بذلتم
جهدا كبيرا ولكن ربما بكيفيه مهينه وبشعه
سيبلغونهم انه ينبغي البدء بمفاوضات ربما
لن تنتهي بالروس وهم ينسحبون تماما من
القرم او الدومباس على الاقل بعد الوقت
سيكون هناك صيف قاس جدا على الاوكرانيين
ومن الجانب الروسي لن يكون امامهم الكثير
من الاريحيه والمرونه بحيث سيتعلق بمدى
قدرتهم على تحمل الالم بسبب طبيعه الحكومه
هناك لذلك وللاسف سيكون الضغط على
الاوكرانيين من اجل ان يبلو البلاء الحسن
وان يبذلوا قصار الجهد وان يكون ذلك برؤيه
واضحه ثم بعد ذلك التفاوض على شيء ما حتى
مع علمهم بان ما قد يحصلون عليه سيكون
مؤقتا فقط مثل ما صرح بذلك الرئيس ديال
انسكي على الاقل حتى نرى قوات روسيا تخرج
من كل اوكرانيا ونعود هنا بعد ثلاثه او
اربع سنوات لانهم قد يكررون ذلك قد يكون
ذلك صحيحا ولكن هناك حدود تفريدها حجم
الاموال وحجم الاقتراض وايضا حجم الصبر
الذي يقع على كاهل داعمي اوكرانيا